the newest adaptation of Stephen King's
it contains a lot of Easter eggs some of
which are more obvious than others in
addition to the ones we've talked about
before like those t-shirt logos here's a
look at some of the other small details
and it's that only true fans noticed the
absentee parents as we see in the
beginning of the movie gary has
instituted a town curfew in reaction to
the disappearances of George Eden bro
Bettie ripped some and others kids are
expected to be home by 7:00 sharp
but that appears to be the full extent
of the adults concern or responsive
action regarding their own children's
well-being this is definitely a
conscious nod to the parents depicted in
the book who prefer to forget about the
town's dark history even ignoring
violence as it happens most of the
parental figures in the film are ones
I've created additional problems for
their children
Robert doe Hayes head during the movies
visual history of the Easter Parade
explosion that claimed the lives of so
many kids there's one particularly
gruesome image that the camera seems to
linger on a boy's head up in a tree
that's a nod to robert doe Hey a
nine-year-old character from the book
whose remains popped up four days after
the rest of the victims in a neighbor's
apple tree and it was just his head
considering all the creepy bug deaths
that didn't make the leap from the page
to the big screen that's an unsettling
one to keep for sure the stutter chant
another thing book readers and fans of
the miniseries will recognize as the
phrase bill uses to overcome his stutter
in the book it's he thrusts his fists
against the posts and still insists he
sees the ghosts in the movie only a
fraction of that is uttered by Bill
perhaps because he's still struggling to
finish it without the second clause it's
a little less creepy but the line is
still seen as a major metaphor for the
story as a whole and he uses it to
regain his self-confidence and strength
in times of trial in the book and movie
alike so it's still effective
I heart Derry Patrick Hawks debtors
death in the movie is nothing like it
was in the book but there is still
something familiar about his fate in the
movie he comes upon a balloon that turns
around to read I heart Derry on it
before it gets him it's ominous enough
standing alone but when you remember the
book story about Adrian melon it's even
worse in the book
Adrian was a gay man he was beaten up
and flung beneath a bridge by some
homophobic bullies
while trying to rescue him his partner
saw the clown and that the overpass was
filled with balloons at the same
phrasing on it and it was a hat with
that I heart dairy logo that started the
attack sequence in the first place
perhaps the reason the balloon came into
play for Patrick here is that in the
books he too exhibited a preference for
a same-sex partner even though that
didn't make it to screen the corner
another wing to the source material is
contained in the location of Georgie's
travels or chasing his paper boat down
the street the camera pans to the street
signs which reveals he's at the
intersection of Jackson and Wickham just
like in the book and the fact that he
runs right into one of the saw horses
are littered the flooded streets well
that's quite literally a book reference
that smacks us in the face Paul Bunyan
when the losers gathered to discuss the
town's killer clown in the park a statue
of Paul Bunyan can be seen a lingering
behind Mike because he fills him in on
what he knows in the book the statue is
not only there but it also comes to life
to taunt Ricci as his own personalized
sphere instead of the clown's perhaps
the reason the statue still made it into
the movie despite not being presented as
Richie's materialized fear factor is
that the statue really does exist in
Stephen King's neck of the woods in
Bangor Maine not only that but it's been
creeping all the locals out since it was
erected I know the difference between a
bad dream in real life okay
the forgetting after they managed to
defeat it for the first time the losers
assemble for what is unbeknownst to them
the last time the seven will be together
like this
they listen to Beverly as she talks
about what it was like to be under the
dead lights of Pennywise and she tells
him that she's already forgetting pieces
of what she experienced that's a
definite bit of foreshadowing for what's
going to come when they grow up and
purge it and the dairy as a whole from
their adult memories until it returns of
course exit order another subtle preview
exists in the order in which the losers
take leave of each other with Stan
departing first and Eddie shortly behind
him as we know from the book second half
is also the order in which they'll
depart in entirely different ways Stan
as an adult is so shaken by the return
of EDS that he takes his own life in the
bathtub and Eddie makes it back to Derry
to fight alongside his childhood
comrades Burt as killed in the battle
before it is ultimately defeated those
might be stories for chapter two but
it wasn't afraid to give fans a little
taste of what's to come here thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]